this week was a uh
a scorcher for a lot of reasons you know
yeah you know
people getting their uh money stolen
getting scammed the ocean was on fire oh
yeah i saw this this is
crazy yeah so the birth godzilla that's
not that we were like
that's not my bit everyone said that
[ __ ] because that's like you know
godzilla comes from the ocean that's
funny though when i saw this i was like
how are they putting it out no putting
water on it i thought this was like some
bad
pr campaign i'm like what dumb
armageddon movie is this for
oh yeah you know and then [ __ ] hugh
jackman flies in you're like oh god oh
my god
global warming is really important
it's the year 2021 shut the [ __ ] up
it's the year 2030. someone's going to
take that as me
thinking not global warming is not real
yeah
yeah it's because it's not because it's
not
joking it's definitely hot it's getting
really really hot yes
the hottest summer that i've felt by far
you know what i'm saying this is what i
was saying it's like
last night i had to we i drove eight
hours this morning right yeah to the
launch spot
to get up to here mm-hmm and uh
i'm so i'm like [ __ ] i gotta go to bed
woke up at 5 30 is i gotta go to bed
early so i get to bed at nine
no ac so i'm just like pouring sweat
like just frustrated too because i know
i have to wake up at 5 30 so i'm sitting
there like
yeah like go to sleep come on i'm too
hot
and you just can't and now it's like ac
needs some every place needs to have ac
you know five years ago it was like or
10 years ago maybe it's like la
west coast whatever we've got breeze
coming in can get away with it
now it's too hot everywhere yeah that's
actually everywhere
all these dooms dave preppers got it
wrong it's not like cans of beans and
guns and [ __ ] it's just ac
yeah just whoever doesn't have ac yeah
like i don't know
12 months is gonna die yeah that's
[ __ ] up
it's true that's like literally it yeah
bro and um i forgot what country it was
damn i wish i remember this it's like
the record hottest summer
and the temperature is past the point
that a human being like it's like the
entire country
it's like if uh if
if the temperature outside is past like
a hundred and like 18 or something
the human body uh the probability of
being able to stand is like
very low or like you physically can't
stand and that that's what it was gonna
is projected to be for like weeks jesus
christ and people are still going to
like their little shops and restaurants
and they're like i gotta get [ __ ]
paid yeah
and it's just gonna be like that yeah i
mean yeah i mean like you know
that's not really a joke about having ac
it's like there's not even going to be
like fighting for beans and [ __ ] you
won't even be able to go outside
yeah it'll be too hot damn that's
depressing as [ __ ]
that's really scary well i just had the
kid cuddy the [ __ ] yeah seriously
isn't it happen like every summer now
it's like new
record-breaking temperatures it's like
this is never happening by accident
no um i'm speaking of things i
not to not to just suck my own little b
dick off
yeah but you know i burned down hassan
uh on on his uh stream oh nice [ __ ] yeah
did a little roast are we playing it
yeah we almost
played it it was short like my set it
was short you all right
i'm your [ __ ] nightmare i wanted to
hear you this is the only time i'm
bigger than you baby
i know all right bam barely
just keep him what is that outfit i like
the outfit actually not yours
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you wearing
dawg i don't know the other night so i
don't have as much prep
um i also haven't done stand-up in a
while i just haven't done this in a
while
um which is you know common for people
who [ __ ] around with hassan so i [ __ ]
that joke
that's what they all say before they get
in his bed that's what i was trying to
say anyway all right here we go
um i want to thank you austin for
inviting me out to this glorified
russian cam girl house
i say that because uh 100 thieves is
used to watching their talent choke on
camera
they had like one of their dudes like
choke like an important gaming
moment recently it's like a girl nah
like cams are all
jokes it's a good thing i didn't go in
on sasha on that [ __ ]
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding had i
known you're going to be here now
you know hassan's a smart guy
intellectuals hate him because he's the
only guy on record to get [ __ ]
from marxism
[Laughter]
[Applause]
for everyone watching at home hassan is
as big as you think he is he's huge i
think he's like 19
5. big legs big shoulders and big hands
which makes it
really nice when he wants to squeeze
your stimulus check for a tier 3 sub
we all know hassan is turkish and
attractive
uh the only time this dude isn't turkish
is when armenian girls send him nudes
turkey and armenia yeah
geopolitical humor yeah dang
hassan uses face app to figure out what
his muslim fans look like without their
hijab
like a girl that one girl's like you
think that's bad
this one might be mean um hassan is
jealous of white people because it's
acceptable for them to [ __ ] their uncles
because his uncle owns the young turtle
no all right
[Applause]
oh jesus um hassan is muslim i was going
to make a 72 virgins in heaven joke but
that'd be wrong
because that's just extremist propaganda
nowhere in the quran is a man promised
virgins
because there are no virgins in heaven
they're all in hassan's chat
that's all i got that last
[Applause]
i didn't go in nearly as hard as
everyone else
what do you mean like man people like
went
oh it was good like you know i was glad
yeah i wasn't sure
what the because when he mentioned that
it was at the 100 thieves place i'm like
oh is this like a super
brand sensitive situation so i'm like
i didn't know and people went the [ __ ]
in really yeah it was great
yeah it tore his ass up what was the
best one that you heard you remember
honestly there's so many like um i know
that's like a cop
out but they're no ev everyone seriously
like tore this dude to
everyone they were like all going at it
like it was it was so [ __ ] funny is
this common on twitch people doing this
um i think it's pretty recent i want to
say
you know big thanks to the austin show
um
the only white guy to get away with
brownface on twitch
uh who who
who um the most famous white indian
remember the raw show no oh wait
wait he was the dating guy yeah yeah
yeah that was that was awesome oh okay
guys that's fine awesome
that was um that was like a lot of
people's bits it was really funny
okay sorry i just completely completely
went over my head that's okay
yeah wow yeah
[Laughter]
yeah the austin show he's um he's the
first indian gamer for 100 thieves
uh yeah so he he put it together and i
think he's done
i want to say he's done a couple before
this but um
cutie cinderella in the middle and the
black that's actually that's ludwig's
girl so
oh nice yeah cool so she was she live in
l.a too
i think i want to say they all live in
austin but i could be wrong no they live
in l.a
oh they live in l.a cool um she tore
hassan and everyone in that room to
pieces he burned that [ __ ] down
so it was great hell yeah yeah